the entire time I knew him he only ever
had one call
[Music]
to wipe out half the universe if he gets
all the Infinity stones she can do it
with the snap of his fingers just like
that tell me his name again Santos
we got one advantage
she's coming to us
we have a dance once so that's what we
use
[Music]
let's talk about this plan here's I
think it's good except it sucks so let
me do the plan and that way it might be
really good
Wow
the end is near
or none done
[Music]
half of humanity will still exist
perfectly balanced
things should be
I hope that remember you
[Music]
I'm Peter by the way dr. strange Oh
using your made-up names then I am
spider-man
grupe morning everyone this is awesome
so they dropped this super early I love
the way they tagged that spider-man joke
at the end
oh we're using our made-up names I'm
spider-man then he's bringing back the
Doctor Strange joke from the Doctor
Strange movie no my name is strange well
Who am I to judge so if you're finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos I'm also
doing an Infinity Gauntlet replica
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video seriously the only
reason I'm not screaming into the
microphone is because it's super early
in the morning when I'm making this
video but one of the greatest things
about the trailer is you know some of
the comic book moments that they
reference like they pick up with that
Gamora speech explaining the Infinity
Gauntlet he could destroy half of all
life in the universe with a snap of his
fingers and then she does the finger
snap from the comics but you actually
get a shot of young Gamora so it does
look like this will be some of the
flashbacks to younger Thanos when she
was growing up when either he'd already
taken her from her home or when he
conquered her home and took her as
tribute but let's just go through this
shot by a shot just because there's so
much stuff we could talk about this all
day so I love the way that they rotate
the camera in that opening shot it's
just like the Black Panther movie so I
guess I should say spoilers for Black
Panther when kill monger becomes king
and they sort of rotate the camera it's
a way visually to tell you that the
narrative is getting flipped on its head
because someone who's supposed to be the
villain is taking over the narrative in
an infinity war it's Thanos that's
taking over the narrative so it's like
he's becoming king of the entire
universe like kill monger was becoming
king of Wakanda even though all the
banner shots that we've seen are either
in the sanctum or in Wakanda this
actually might be in the New Avengers
facility before they go to Wakanda like
when they're loading up the Quinn jet to
fly out you just get shots of all the
different areas that the Avengers pop up
in like you can see against the
background of the sanctum here like the
ship is actually reflected in the glass
just careening across the sky then you
see Iron Man shoot up after it you get a
much clearer version of the shot we got
from the teaser yesterday so the really
cool thing about the bleeding-edge armor
that we've kind of known but we haven't
really seen really good shots of is they
just reconfigures itself as Iron Man
needs it to the same way
Black Panthers costume can use nanites
to just form around him the thing here
though is that his Gamora starts her
voiceover explained the Infinity
Gauntlet she's actually on the Milano
talking to the other Guardians and
anybody else that might be on the ship
at that moment probably to Thor because
he picks up with them relatively early
in the film but here you can actually
see Iron Man inside the sanctum talking
to dr. strange
so that actually happens relatively
early in the film too because strange is
one of the few people that actually has
really detailed information on the
Infinity stones but if you haven't read
the prequel comic I've already done a
couple videos explaining that story
they basically explain Doctor Strange
talking to Wong about the location of
the Infinity stones what each of them do
the danger that they sense that's coming
this really crazy cosmic unease that's
in the air that they can sense what
their magic so he contacts Iron Man he
shows up at the sanctum and you pick up
with banner like crashing right through
that skylight tell me his name again
it's almost like volta more speak his
name and the devil shall appear you see
this fire in the background here is he's
pulling his helmet off this actually
might be on Thor ship because there's a
couple of different shots with Loki's
standing with the black order later in
the trailer in Thanos grabs the
tesseract and smashes it so that he
could take the space gem out and put it
in the gauntlet like look at the
gauntlet here right now he only has the
power gem in it so he's already been to
Xander so I don't know that they're
gonna deny us that pleasure so that
might be just some sort of condensed
sequence at the beginning of the film
because the total runtime I think is
about two hours and 36 minutes making it
the longest Marvel film that they've
ever made by a couple minutes civil war
is only a couple minutes shorter than
that so it's not like it's way longer
than the longest Marvel film so far but
even so some of the sequences where he
takes certain gems will probably be
quicker than others like the mind gem is
gonna be one of the longest ones because
like Iron Man says we have what he wants
we'll use that so vision living
MacGuffin gets taken to Wakanda you get
a much longer shot of Peter on his class
field trip making a beeline for that
ship this is Doctor Strange after that
shot of Banner crashing through and
everybody freaking out and heading for
the door
so Doctor Strange is like all right
activate the time Jim time to throw down
because this is happening with all this
greenery behind them
might be after they've gone to Wakanda
when vision is just like sitting there
waiting for the attack to come like
everybody just waiting for Thanos to rip
that gem right out of his forehead
welcome back to Wakanda cap you get a
better shot of vision and everybody
climbing out of the Quinjet
you see roadies new harness that he
walks in like I don't think it was gonna
be too much trouble for Iron Man 2 magic
some tech up for him so even though his
spine is probably gonna be damaged for
the rest of his life he'll still move
around like a totally normal person in
the movie I think I already talked about
it during all of my Black Panther
post-credit scene videos and Easter Egg
videos but for the most part
anybody that survived the Black Panther
movie is going to show up during
infinity war even Everett Ross although
you don't really see him anywhere in
these trailers sure he has vision on the
table examining the mind gem she was
responsible for fixing winter soldiers
mind in the prequel comic she brags that
they're AI technology is more advanced
than the technology used to create
Ultron which was the technology used to
create vision just a really big hat tip
for what she might eventually be doing
programming messin with visions mind so
that they could extract the mind gem
like you could see the digital
representation of all this yellow of the
energy from the mind gem inside his
brain looking for a safe way to separate
him from that because Thanos is gonna
assemble the gauntlet so that means that
it's coming out of his forehead one way
or another think of all the broken white
boys coming to Shuri
right after this giant battle with the
outriders I love the way that they're
all banging up against that wakandan
shield raise all defenses get that man a
shield because you see the Guardians
climbing out on this station and you see
the trawler here that looks like it
might be on nowhere this might be them
trying to get to the collector before
Thanos does I actually posted a video
with that scene so I had a link for it
at the end of this but it's basically
Thanos stepping on the collector just
trying to squeeze the life out of him
finding out what he did with the reality
gem this is probably the truest real
comedy scene next to that spider-man
Doctor Strange moment here's the thing
you're playing real good but it sucks
let's do my plan so it doesn't suck it
was that video that I posted with
Captain America and Black Widow where
the interviewer was asking them you know
what's it like having to quippy pee
like Chris Pratt and Robert Downey jr.
on screen together he's like well you
know we pepper that in there it's not
like they're on screen together all the
time since we don't see any shots of
Iron Man on the Milano I'm wondering if
they actually crash on Titan inside
Thanos's ship like maybe they make their
way inside then the ship goes back to
Titan but separately the Guardians also
come to tighten the look on Peters face
is Iron Man just gets so tired of
listening to Chris Pratt is hilarious
this is just like the underoos moment
during civil war Iron Man's having
flashbacks oh my god I'm getting tired
of hearing this other person talking to
my ear Peter is basically the audience
proxy like he can't hardly believe
what's going on he's so excited to be
here
much bigger shot of that wakandan battle
you see the ships that they ride out to
on I'm sure they'll be selling those in
stores like that's part of the point of
these movies is selling a lot of toys in
addition to being really cool much
better shot of Bucky with his vibranium
arm Inspector Gadget style we've talked
about how that arm can probably do other
things like reconfigure to make other
weapons if he needs to like cap has the
gauntlets that turn into the shield's we
haven't talked about it a whole lot but
I think we all agree that the Hulk is
inside the Hulkbuster for at least part
of the film so most of you probably
could tell that this is the Hulkbuster
2.0 it's just an upgraded version of the
one that we saw during age of Ultron
there's a really cool extended scene of
Thor getting ready to forge his new
Stormbreaker weapon with rocket in
adolescent Groot much better shot of
Thanos in his full armor with his
classic helmet on this obviously looks
like that flashback scene that I was
talking about earlier in the video with
him with Gamora it might be her original
home planet that he came to conquer with
the Chitauri more than just standing
around haven't really seen the Chitauri
in a while after the Avengers blew up
most of their fleet
I loved Anna's voiceover - perfectly
balanced hopefully they remember you but
he has that funny glasses half-full
comment where he says well you know half
of all life will still be alive when he
is grabbing Thor's head here - squeezing
him like a grape this might be happening
really early in the film when he boards
the Asgardian ship like I said this is
the black order this is probably when
they come to take the space gem Loki
probably trades it and his allegiance to
them in order to spare most of
people's lives although there's a lot of
dead people in the background here but
we finally get better shots of the Black
Order so from left to right you have
Proxima midnight
evany ma Corvus glaive and then Kol
obsidian like I said you know his name's
black dwarf in the comics but in the
movie he's being called Kol obsidian in
the comics the name of the entire team
is Kol obsidian Kevin Feige said that
really early in the film there'll be a
couple moments that will tell you
exactly how big bad and powerful Thanos
is squeezing the tesseract and cracking
it like a walnut is one of those moments
the thing about this though is that when
the Hulkbuster is in this fight we've
actually seen Hulk running behind
Captain America I'm wondering when he
finally becomes Hulk again because there
been a lot of rumors about banners arc
during the film and for the most part
he's banner in all the footage we've
seen so unless they're misleading us at
some point he will be able to become the
Hulk again and the Hulkbuster will just
be remote piloted by Friday or some
other AI maybe they stick one of her
vibranium receivers on it and she just
remote pilots the Hulkbuster from her
lab that actually be pretty badass
pretty cool combination of powers here
on the Titan battle so you have Doctor
Strange creating his glyphs so that
star-lord can run across the battlefield
this is probably one of my favorite
shots though is ebony ma coming for dr.
Strange's time gem and you could just
see like loki tried to come after dr.
strange during thor ragnarok and he just
totally threw him out of one of those
portals but ebony ma is supposed to be
so much more badass that they make it
look like his magic is more powerful the
doctor Strange's like their powers
aren't exactly the same evident ol
manipulation that he is about raw
sorcery but i think in the movie they'll
present him as being like a dark version
of dr. strange in terms of his abilities
love the way they cut these to Thanos
shots to so him jumping at frame you
know obviously coming at the Avengers
while they're on Titan then separately
coming for Captain America while they're
in Wakanda so that you can see all this
greenery very clearly fan OHS is here
during this battle in Wakanda coming for
the mind gem it's just that this is the
first time we've seen him but it's
really more meant to show you how strong
Captain America is obviously Thanos is
way more powerful and even though we
only see two gems in the gauntlet this
might be one of those Thor Ragnarok
CGT trickery moments where we're not
seeing exactly the way it's going to
happen when we get the theatrical cut of
the film like okay we're just gonna
delete a couple of the gems here so
people don't know how many he has when
he makes it to Wakanda really awesome
dextrous shot of spider-man swinging
through all the ruins of Titan here the
only bummer is that he doesn't have his
iron spider arms on we all know about
that at this point so I feel like it's
not a spoiler but let me know in the
comments what your favorite part of this
and obviously I'll be doing bonus videos
about some of this stuff for the next
couple of days but just let me know in
the comments which videos you want me to
start with first so congratulations to
the giveaway winner from my last big
video Jorge buyer
please private message me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
contact details I'll name a new winner
when I post new Marvel which will be
tomorrow so no worries click here for
more of those infinity war promos that
they've been dropping and click here
turn about the New Gods movie the DC
just announced that's totally crazy
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]